when someone engages in something that
is
transformative there's an emotional
process you're transforming the way you
handle money you're transforming
uh your uh uh your body you're going
through weight loss or working out or
getting ready for a marathon
or you are transforming a marriage from
a bad situation to a good situation
transforming your parenting skills or
whatever
it always feels like as a lay person
that doesn't know what he's talking
about that getting
through the first 10 takes more or 20
takes more energy than the rest of the
80
like he talked about he had to kind of
muscle through it for a little while and
then they found their groove
yep i had a friend that used to say the
hardest run of the day was from his
couch to the front door
if i could just get to the front door
then i can go run my five miles yeah but
it's just getting up and getting out
there yeah
there's something about changing
behaviors that are wired into us there's
something about changing thought
patterns that just are so default and so
normed in our life that it just it's
hard to
set that dial back and once you get that
thing set back as he mentioned once you
go from a math problem
to a visioning gift right once you go
from solving a problem to
a new way of living towards something it
just changes everything
psychologically speaking yeah if you've
been doing something wrong to reset
and get your default to not be
uh because your default is comfortable
but it's wrong that's right
and to change your default to uh
the not the natural go-to is the right
thing
that requires just tremendous energy it
does it's hard and sometimes it's
you've got to go all the way back and
look where you're wired that's where
rachel's book's coming out it's talking
about where your where your history is
which is so good rachel cruz
and some folks are just blessed with an
ability to say no more i'm moving
forward
and i envy those people personally i
know one or two of them that just
stop smoking i'm just i'm done with it
i'm going to move on the majority of us
have to go find out where those
behaviors are from and really get
someone to walk alongside us why this
thing's a math problem well it turns
those automatic behaviors
into going towards something yeah why is
it that when that happens i'm angry
yep why is it what is it that does that
what's that
what's my brain protecting me from
what's my heart trying to protect me
from why is anger my tool to go to
and some people go to curling up in a
ball and some people go and go to
yelling
and just stopping and asking yourself
what am i trying to defend myself from
yeah what's what
what is this reminding me of there you
go yeah and there's got to be something
that's
there's a real because when people say
they change their lives
at walking through the stuff we're
talking about all we're doing is talking
about money i mean we're talking about
credit cards and mutual funds
so why is that so life-changing it's
because it's behavior change
it's 80 behavior it's only 20 math
and so what you're really having to do
is really rewire your dad gum brain
and it just it's hard it's real hard and
i think those things
pop up 10 years later 20 years later
you'll see them come up you'll meet
somebody you'll get in a situation that
somehow there's there's a great book by
bessel vander cult called the body keeps
the score
you'll your body will respond to
something 10 years later 15 years later
that happened to me last night
i ordered an extra apple we went out
with another couple for dinner sharing
that
and i got this huge massive seafood
appetizer for the whole table
just because i wanted it right and
sharon's like
what'd you do that for right and her
whole body changed
i'm like you're not broke woman you can
afford a freaking appetizer
but she's like you know there's a dave's
wasting money
from 40 years ago thing comes out every
once in a while
[Applause]
jumped across the table stole my oysters
you know but it's like
oh man i can't even enjoy a freaking
appetizer but yeah it
that's but i've watched it physically
activating her
so i had a situation a couple of weeks
ago that i talked about
on this new show where i got to work on
time and if you
if you don't know working for dave
ramsey one of the cornerstones is you
will be here on time
i got here a little bit early because
i'm usually rushing around it was a
staff meeting i walk in the door and my
wife calls
and we just have this we moved to this
new place out in the woods
and she calls and says please go check
in your truck and see if my keys are in
there
and my son had gone to get something out
of my truck and had left her keys and my
show started filming
exactly one hour it's 30 minutes there
and
i got instantly angry i'm gonna teach
that k
and then i had to on my walk back to the
parking lot i remember having to think
why am i why why am i so mad because
something happened that i can't control
by the time i got home i was laughing
i hugged him and said everyone talked
about this tonight and i was able to
address him in a way that a 10 year old
can hear it right if you lose your keys
again you have to ride on the tube
behind mr davis boat again
again he was completely traumatized he's
still
he's still trying to clutter still
traumatized that's right